[Music]
Thank you everyone for coming here. I
hope you're uh excited to figure out
with me what enterprise ready MCP means.
Uh I'm not sure a month ago people even
fully understood what MCP meant. Um so
we're all on this journey together. Um,
but hopefully it should be fun.
So, I was chatting to a good friend and
colleague who is is giving a talk
tomorrow on building MCP servers and
what it looks like to build that out.
And his question was, how do the tools
of today map to the AI systems of
tomorrow? We already have some kind of
not concept of enterprise ready tooling
and building tools for the enterprise
and production. What does it actually
mean for MCP and something I kind of,
you know, want to talk through today,
chat with you guys. So for a long time
from you know several years now we've
had the model of you are a user you talk
to an AI talk to a chatbot it does stuff
the AIS had tool calling now they have
MCP this is the MCP logo which is just a
way of interfacing between the AI and an
external resource of some kind to do
something right can just be a database
access it can be performing some
complicated computation can be pulling
in a prompt there's lots of stuff in the
MCP spec that frankly you should go and
read there's more there than most people
realize
We're also seeing workloads like this
where an IT admin spins up an
asynchronous workflow which is we're
going to call an AI agent which
automates some process that is you know
kind of headless and is going and doing
a thing we're trying to manage that that
is then going to use MCP to access
external tools that might be secured
might be internal enterprise tools which
introduce some fun problems. I also for
the sake of this kind of diagram of what
is the future going to look like want to
introduce this line here just to throw
some some spanners in the works of users
in a company using their chatbot which
makes a call to an MCP server which then
goes and queries an AI workload an AI
agent that's existing in the cloud
performing some operation and so with
this kind of diagram of what could
happen I want us to figure out what we
need to fix to make this really useful
and production
Okay, why am I why am I talking to you?
I work for WorkOS, which is an
enterprise security vendor, um, which
I'll talk about in a second. I'm also a
research fellow at Stanford working on
safety for AI agents and just finished a
PhD where I got to wear this really
funny, silly hat, um, just a couple
months ago. Um, OpenAI uh work OS is a
enterprise security vendor that sells to
all of the AI labs because the AI labs
do not want to do the really painful
annoying work to scale the security and
orth operations into the enterprise. And
so we've been thinking a lot about what
it means to provide the glue that means
people can build agents and then just
seamlessly scale it and sell it to
everyone. And so I want to just tell you
all the answers today whether or not you
want to use us. So let's go through the
agent journey. We're all here trying to
build agents. Um, let's tell a tell a
story. So, I found this great API um
that you can query and it will feed a
bunch of goats that you can then see on
a live stream. Um, this is a real API
you can go and use. And so, naturally,
you do what anyone would do and you're
going to build an emotional support bot
for employees at a company to build a
SAS. Um, and you give it tool use to
query this. Now, this is fine because
it's a onetime query, but frankly, tool
use kind of sucks. We've had it for
years now. Not as many people are using
it. It's really painful. A lot of things
go wrong, which is why the model context
protocol got invented. So why would you
move to to MCP?
One, there is this really robust
ecosystem of tools and providers,
security tooling that lets you interface
between the model and the resource to
make things safe and reliable. It's also
really good at providing standardization
to the models. the models are getting
really good at learning how to use this
either through RL or just kind of you
know good eval usage. It also runs a
stateful connection which means you can
do you know better security better
management better context management in
the way you're passing in to an AM model
and maybe you're doing it just because
everyone's doing it and why not have
some fun right it is genuinely quite fun
to build an MCP server you can make cool
things out of it so what do we do we
make our local server right hopefully at
some point everyone's had a little play
with this uh you tweet out check out my
local host um you know try and get your
friends to play with it it's great it's
hacky it's not particularly useful to
anyone except yourself. You can build
some fun local service. Frankly, this is
where we see a lot of people building
MCP right now. It's an internal demo.
You're going to see if you can connect
it to an API. Cool. It works. And then
we don't go much further than that.
And so kind of the next step where
everyone has been talking about a lot of
discussion in the community, how do we
do this really robustly is just adding
authentication, authorization to these
workloads, which is truthfully right now
the main thing you need to do. These are
links to docs that will help you do it.
Uh through there you can come and chat
with me and I will sit down with you
anywhere in the world and help you build
a really robust secure MCP server and
figure out some pain points. Um you
should not have an external API that is
unauthenticated that has no access
controls on it. Uh things will go very
wrong. So super simple you make people
log in. You scope you have an admin
privilege so that no one is feeding the
goats too much. you know, make sure
goats are well maintained and kept safe.
Um, and maybe if you're doing this
internally with an organization, you put
in a VPC, you're doing that gateway to
make sure no one can access they should,
but everyone turns out in your
organization loves your goat emotional
support tool because who wouldn't? And
so you do what what anyone would do. You
you say, "Let's make it public. Let's
make a public MCP server that people can
add to their claude, that people can
build applications on top of. Let's add
a stripe in there to make sure they've
got payment rails. just sends back a URL
that you can call out to click things.
It's pretty straightforward. Um, you
give some users free credits because,
you know, this is how apps work. Uh, and
you put it on a cloud hosting solution.
Tons and tons of them are spinning up.
You get ads and announcements about them
every day. Fundamentally, MCP servers
are just a normal workload, which means
a lot of the cloud hosting providers can
support whatever you need to host. And
so there's there's lots and lots that we
can discuss there. But you do this
really well, and everyone loves goat
feeding and emotional support. So, you
end up going viral. You've got a
billboard on the highway. Mr. Beast
tweets you out. What happens now? You
end up with having way too much
traction, right? You get free credit
abuse on the signups. Uh, this is
something that we see a ton of AI
companies that we support happening is
AI companies give you some free credits
to onboard you, but at the end of the
day, they're just querying an AI API,
which means that folks will sign up for
an account, abuse those free credits,
and cycle back. one of the AI vendors uh
that we work with, someone was using
their free credits to write fanfiction
stories um by just this is not an
application designed for writing
fanfiction just because it's a
convenient way to get free credits and
so you end up needing bot blocking on
signups. Um you need kind of robust
controls over the whole orth stack to
make sure nothing goes wrong. Uh you're
going to end up needing uh input
validation so that no one prompt
injection attacks your goats. Got to
keep them safe. Uh and then there's a
lot of niche stuff that happens with
MCP. So, uh MCP servers dynamically
register their clients with the server,
which means if you have any developer
admin dashboard, application dashboard
that's tracking the applications that
you've created, they will suddenly be
flooded with MCP servers because of this
weird choice in how MCP servers register
as applications. And so essentially
every orth stack you need, every like
management tooling you need needs to be
adapted for MCP. And so this is
something that we provide but also like
a bunch of other people are working on
and something to be conscious of is if
you scale things will start going very
wrong.
And so everyone loves your MCP server
that's super cool. Maybe it's just an AI
AI agent wrapping it or you're selling
the core MCP server. You want to sell
into enterprise. What do we have to do?
This is like a well-worn SAS path that
we're going to go through. You have to
do all of the boring stuff. You have to
do the SSO, the life cycle management.
You're going to have to do provisioning.
Um, Block uh are this super cool company
um that developed Goose. And internally,
they've been provisioning AI like access
to this client, this chat client as well
as MCP servers. And I really see a
future where enterprises use SSO to
provision access to a ton of internal
resources exposed via MCP that then
employees can chat with as a you know
default way that employees are
encouraged to use AI to automate
workflows.
And so if you're going to sell into the
enterprise, you end up needing all this
like nitty-gritty stuff that really
sucks. Fine grand access controls that
are highly performant are really robust
audit logs um for instant responses. A
lot of the regulations that exist right
now like GDPR um call out explicitly
additional requirements on logging for
AI workloads because the regulators like
to regulate and so your audit logs that
exist normally have to fit a very
specific set of requirements which are
not well supported widely and so
something to think about as you scale
these workloads. Um and you need stuff
like data loss preventions so that
people aren't like uploading random
things to MCP servers. This becomes a
significant risk when people are just
chatting wildly with a ton of servers.
And so now you have an enterprise ready
serverish
because there are a lot of other
questions to answer. This this is a talk
that was was hidden to tell you the
answers, but truthfully the answers
aren't entirely known yet and the
protocol is very rapidly developing.
And so this is the the diagram we
started off with. This stuff's super
easy, right? How does a user log into an
AI chat? Done. We've solved that. How do
AI systems connect to MCP servers? This
is something that's being worked on.
It's pretty straightforward. We can do
all there. You can scan those QR codes
from before, build it, and you have a
production ready MCP server. MCP servers
connecting to external resources is
pretty straightforward. It's not too
hard to do. Can be a bit annoying, but
you know, you have to pass your scopes
and do it properly. Um, IT admins
managing AI workloads pretty
straightforward. And in theory, you
know, the other end of MCP servers
existing in your tenency connecting to
resources, bit of a pain point, but can
easily be built. There are lots of open
questions still as to how we do this.
Um, how exactly remote asynchronous
workloads can do headless or off into
MCP servers with dynamic client
registration uh and make sure that is
you have correct authorization controls.
It's actually super hard and things keep
going wrong along the way. um how these
asynchronous workloads call out to
relevant users. Uh there is a a new RFC
in the MCP spec for elicitation. So when
your model doesn't know what to do, it
knows that it should ask a human being
and this is becoming supported as part
of MCP that it can go and call out
towards a user um and say please provide
additional input that you need because
I'm missing details. So stuff like this
is actively developing and nothing is
stable. Um and then there's this very
broad question that we're running into
with AI workloads um of uh passing scope
between different AI workloads passing
access control between AI workloads
where if you have the A2 we're talking
about MCP if you're using A2A protocol
you are just telling an agent mostly in
vibes what it should or shouldn't do and
relying upon the alignment of that model
to make sure it doesn't misbehave and so
actually passing robust authorization
you know scopes uh communicating access
controls making sure that service
account that AI workload might be has
the correct access turns out to be a
huge pain point in doing this. So
frankly the cloud vendors are mostly
solving the cloud hosting. I think the
authorization and access control element
of this is the hardest part of putting
this into external enterprise workloads
um and a big thing that needs to be
filled.
So
if you want to build fun things, we are
actively building out this entire stack
to sell to AI companies and startups. Uh
and if you go to the docs, we can build
some cool stuff together. Um everyone is
building interesting things right now.
And you know, it's fun to get into the
nitty-gritty and and see what bugs
occur. And then as a thank you for all
listening to this fun talk, uh you
cannot use this on your phones. To be
clear, you can buy this shirt only
through MCP.
Uh the instructions are on the website.
Uh very briefly, if you'd like to see,
let me see if I can get out of this um
and go to cursor. You have to add the
MCP server. There are many ways to do
this, but the way I'd recommend is just
going into one of your AI um editors, uh
typing in the JSON that the website will
give you. This is like the easiest way
to add. You'll see that it's turned on.
You'll need to make an account because
authorization, access control, etc. Um
and then you can say, "Please buy me a
shirt.
Um, and of course the Wi-Fi um will not
work.
Beautiful. Will need my mailing address.
One, two, three. Hack away. Um, work OS.
And I want a medium.
And it knows my name. It's authorized.
It's done a validation check on me.
We've got a bot blocker on the signup so
that people can't abuse my shirts. And
you'll see right there that we purchased
a shirt. So, let's go back to Keynote.
um scan it, add it to your computer if
you want. Um and you guys can have a
free very nice MCP shirt uh that I would
love to share around. Thank you very
much.
[Music]